i feel like i've been so strong-minded
and sometimes i blame that on you know
being single for so long not really
having to compromise or share anything
so now i'm agreeing for a prenup yep how
you feeling how you feel about that
shaida agrees to sign the prenup
and the s word seems to have played a
huge part in that decision
i want to have a relationship where
i know when to submit to you and be
submitted submissive rather than
like everything you say i don't have to
fire back and before some of y'all jump
through the screen don't worry she's not
the only one compromising
[Music]
and yes we're going to talk about the s
word
it's either yes or no
that you want to have a child
before you turn 40. i would like to see
it
in writing as well it's going to be
interesting to see if some of your minds
change about bilal after this episode
probably not
we'll see let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia
i hope you're doing well a few quick
updates before we hop into shaida's big
decision cara and guillermo got married
yup they've been having their ups and
downs she likes to control me a lot
go out and drink
but they made it and they're so in love
congrats call me your wife
that's my wife
she liked the thing she liked that movie
no i'm just excited
in every way oh my god so see you
i know i don't talk about them that much
but they are officially the first couple
to say i do this season
you don't have to care but at least now
you know also
you're so sweet
wow
muhammad proposes to eve
which i'm confused about because aren't
they engaged already
isn't that how you get the k1 visa
they've literally been planning a
wedding but anyway the proposal comes
after muhammad has tried to convert even
to a muslim woman complained about the
way she dresses and even threaten to get
someone else to sponsor him
do you saying this to me is like making
me feel like you think that i'm just
replaceable do you like love me and like
look if you love me you will understand
i know that goals and if
that's your dream i have another dreams
if i'm not allowed to work in this
country i will okay so it's all about
asia
but after speaking with his mom who was
back in egypt
yana muhammad is a mama's boy
he has done a complete 180.
his mom takes eve's side and tells him
he needs to accept her for who she is
and adjust to how we do things in
america
i am amazed about what my mom said she's
completely in east side
and i didn't expect that and goodness
the effect his mom has on him is
powerful
i haven't seen muhammad act romantic
toward eve this entire season
so throughout most of these scenes right
here i was rolling my eyes
it's like come on y'all just give it up
muhammad you can try to change
good luck
and eve you can hope he changes
good luck
although she said yes for a second time
you can tell that she's doubtful that
he's truly going to accept her for who
she is
maybe muhammad is trying to be a little
more
understanding
but it's hard
because i still feel very guarded
why do we hold on to things that bring
us more stress than peace why do we do
this to ourselves
we are like days away from the wedding
and right now we are at odds all right
moving on let's get into the biggest
must-see moment this episode between
shaida and balau
at this point these two only have 10
days left to get married and chada still
doesn't feel right signing the prenup
especially without adding the new
conditions she brought up in last week's
episode
having children at a certain time
as well as
assisting me to start my business in kc
so in search for some advice on how to
move forward shaida invites bilal's mom
over
and it's cool to see the bond she and
chaita share it seems to be genuine plus
below's mom was married to his dad
before he passed away for a very long
time so the wisdom she's about to share
is from experience i know there's no
such thing as a perfect marriage but you
guys have spent so much time together
right and i was like you know what i
want to be married for a very long time
well i think
you're on the right path when you
realize that marriage is not perfect
it's two imperfect human beings
holding on to each other and not letting
go
hmm
i felt that
that type of relationship i know it's
something that doesn't come overnight
chada goes on to tell balau's mom that
she hears her but at the same time
she thinks bilal is too business
oriented when it comes to their marriage
you're feeling that a prenup is saying
you don't trust me
absolutely
here comes another gym ears up
when it comes to trust what does trust
really mean it means different things to
different people
some people will say
i will trust you until you show me that
i can't trust you okay
some people will say
you have to show me before i can trust
you
neither way is right or wrong it's just
how that person feels bilal's mom goes
on to share that it took him a long time
to open up his heart again because he's
been hurt before
he has opened up
his heart
to let you in
and by that some of the fears of of uh
leaving
so these are triggers
yeah
one thing i've learned personally in my
life is that romantic love has the power
to bring out the best in you but
it also has the power to bring out the
worst in you
if you have things that you still need
to work on heal
which most of us do love will trigger
them
but that's why i think it's important to
not only be honest with yourself and
address what you need to work on but if
you're going to be in a relationship
it's important to have a partner who is
aware of your past experiences and does
their best to try to understand how
those experiences affected you so they
can love you better and assist you in
letting those fears go
allah has put the male
as the head of the family
okay the submission talk is about to
start coming into play
i know this can be a controversial topic
and it can get divisive but
let's all try to keep an open mind here
okay everyone has the right to choose
how they want to operate in a
relationship
all right
allah has put the male
as the head of the family
and he leads
and we follow
but there's ways that we can leave from
behind
but you always leave him with his
manhood
the male is sometimes maybe not as
tactful oh you can say that again
don't get salty men we love y'all
the male is sometimes maybe not as
tactful
but when you are in that leadership
position
it's not a dictator
so i have tried to teach all of my sons
to be strong
but yet tender
but the back and forth going back and
forth if it gets to that
you know there's no winners
we have to learn that
being right is not the most important
thing
and will it matter five years from now
um yeah that prenup will but
i get the overall point she's trying to
make bilal's mom goes on to say that all
her son wants is peace and comfort and
she tells shaida
if you know you have a good man
figure out how to make it work and bring
in the peace this is when chada starts
to get emotional
because she feels as if she's been
approaching this prenup conversation all
wrong
when it comes to
like trying to be right
some things i need to let go
not always having to be right is
something below should consider working
on too
it's also something i have to remind
myself from time to time and let me just
say this i admire schneider for not
neglecting her needs for the sake of
what blou wants
i don't think she should be hard on
herself about the choices she's made so
far
it just shows how much you really care
and it's okay
i know he thinks the world of you
i know that
he's told me that many times
gosh
but to a certain extent he's still
guarded
but i don't feel that
he is as guarded as he was
two years ago
and each day
your love will grow his love will grow
wow
talk about getting practical when it
comes to relationships this is real talk
and i know a lot of us have opinions
about bilal
but what continues to pop up in my head
is that shada is a grown intelligent
woman who is choosing to be with him
she has made the choice and with that
choice comes accepting him for where he
is right now
the last moment explaining to me that
her son was hurt badly and it took him a
while to open back up his heart to
others
shadow says she's realizing that she and
bilal have not been having the
conversations they should have been
having instead they've been bickering
and fighting
i don't know what it is about this
episode but the moms are coming through
they are teaching compromise i feel as
if the possibility of his heart closing
in is like huge right now
and it would absolutely pain me to know
that
i am the demise of my relationship and i
don't want to be the the demise of my
relationship she's such a good woman
and the way she and bilal's mom in the
conversation is so sweet
sure can i get some advice from bilal's
mom not even in shaida's position but i
felt comforted it had been nailed to
everything
it hit didn't you like
what else you got
all is well all that's good so much i
think that's compensation
yeah i love you
[Music]
all right let's move on to when she
finally tells below her decision
started cooking late because my mom was
here and i was entertaining her oh how
did that go
i like i don't know i got all the
emotional ontario and mom probably
wonder
what is happening with her shadow tells
him that his mom spoke to her soul and
said exactly what she needed to hear
she then brings up submission and says
she wants to have a relationship where
she knows when to let him lead and
submit
everything you say i don't have to fire
back and i think it's vice president
everything i say you don't have to fire
back
i feel like i've been so strong-minded
and sometimes i blame that on you know
being single for so long not really
having to compromise or share anything
so now i'm agreeing for a prenup
because i feel like we have been
back and forth and this has caused so
much friction in our relationship
so i'm willing to submit i think before
i was feeling figuratively speaking i
was feeling so naked like i needed
something
what i'm just trying to look for in
security before i share my brief
thoughts on submission and yes i said
brief because uh i am not about to set
myself up like i said this can be a very
controversial topic and while y'all know
i'm not someone to shy away from hard
conversations
i just honestly don't think this is a
platform to go that deep into it
but before i give my take below shares
his thoughts on shadow wanting to submit
to him what do you say lisa what do you
say thinking about what i look for in a
potential spouse i really necessarily
wouldn't say like
submit you know because you know we
submit to god
um
but i would say just
it was just refreshing that she came to
a point that said you know like i'm
willing to be open
i think that's how you have a beautiful
marriage be able to listen and
communicate effectively smart answer
bilal
okay when it comes to me and my house
i'm not even married yet but
when it comes to this
here's where i am right now and this is
just my opinion i'm not saying everyone
has to think this way this is her being
vulnerable based on my life experience
so far
at this point the word submission
doesn't scare me
but i think there are certain levels to
it the level that i'm comfortable with
because i do see myself as an alpha
woman is allowing my man to lead when it
comes to certain family and household
decisions
but let's be clear
no one is the leader of me as an
individual at the end of the day i'm
always going to trust my gut
and also as my husband you only gain my
submission when you prove to me that
your decisions are trustworthy and a
win-win for both of us
i'll be darned if i'm out here following
someone who doesn't know what the heck
they're doing
but let me reiterate this again because
sometimes you have to do that for the
internet
this is my opinion and i think everyone
should go about relationships in a way
that serves them best it's not a one
size fit all
right all right back to that
conversation
below's reacting to shada saying she's
going to sign the prenup but she was
hesitant because she didn't feel secure
i 100 see where you're coming from yeah
all i'm trying to do is just also let
you see where
i'm coming from
and by no means it's not a way to say
you know like
i won't take care of you not like i i
mean i've proven
that i've i continue to do that you know
it's just a way to say you know what let
me can i protect myself as well to
protect what i do have
i'm all about whatever you want to do
for his yoga stuff speaking of the yoga
stuff balau agrees to put in the prenup
that he will invest in her business and
allow her to fully own it
future business booming here in the
states
we don't even have to have that in
premium we can put it in there for sure
well it seems like i'm taking the advice
below mother gave me when she was like
you know sometimes you'll allow the man
to lead and you lead from behind just by
me saying i will sign no matter what and
not demanding what i want to put in a
prenup bilal offered to put it in anyway
and in my mind i look at it as you know
him being the head and i'm the neck
shot is so happy
she also brings up putting in the prenup
that they will try to have a child
before she turns 40.
for context she's 37. it's either yes or
that you want to have a child
before you turn 40. yeah but it's just
like we all on the same page when it
comes to having children
and i would like to see it
in writing as well if that's okay
i can i can agree to that
yeah
look at shadow she's like yeah let's go
make a baby now
i'm just kidding
i don't think right now at this very
moment would be the best decision to
have a child i just have concerns of
having children too early because with
her coming to the country and so much
other different things i feel like it
can be too much on us but i'm willing to
do whatever it takes to not lose her
so
for those of you who are not a fan of
bilal what are your thoughts after this
do you see him in a new light or
nah i'm willing to do whatever it takes
to not lose her oh side note you know
one thing i can't wait for
their wedding
one thing i think most of us can agree
on is how beautiful of a couple they are
they are going to look good
look at shaida she is stunning with this
pink lip and pink hijab
and below is looking like
[Music]
it is nothing like a chocolate man in a
suit and speaking of the wedding next
week it looks like shada is going to see
her wedding dress for the first time
shaida your wedding dress is ready come
on up and finally get to see the wedding
dress that bilal's sister made for me
what do you think
this is not a style that i sent you
an old lady dress a hideous dress this
is a true stress sometimes the customer
don't really like know what they want
i'm thinking this is another prank
i hope so at least
all right 90 day fans fam thank you for
taking a ride with me through such a
complex topic today make sure you stick
with e.t because we are covering it all
i will see you next time